[Music]
Sandra's back Johnny's back Estelle's
back everybody is back yeah almost
everybody and whoever didn't do it you
know we'll bring them back in if we get
a continuation it's been mere hours
since news broke of Roseanne's
cancellation after the show's title star
wrote a racist tweet about Barack
Obama's former White House advisor
Valerie Jarrett Roseanne apologized
Tuesday morning and said she was leaving
Twitter but she clearly had a lot to say
Tuesday night first the comedian
acknowledged her cast and crew writing I
just want to apologize to the hundreds
of people and wonderful writers all
liberal and talented actors who lost
their jobs then she said sorry about her
insensitive and tasteless tweet to
Valerie
directly but it doesn't end there
Roseanne blamed her tweet on
circumstances writing that it was 2:00
in the morning and I was ambien tweeting
what are we supposed to do a production
source tells et that the Roseanne cast
and crew is in shock over everything and
there's been a lot of texting back and
forth the source said Roseanne had no
filter on set and would take a lot of
coaxing to get her down which she would
get riled up